well there's a reason today's target is
been so tough to grab dude smart and
crafty as hell
nothing's gonna beat number two the
little guy with the Gatling you had that
gun was as big as he was he shot the
hell out of it though Benny I appreciate
you riding with us or a man down there
alone as Mitch was crazy enough to give
you a team I'll pinch it any time sweet
says hello
oh yeah how's it doing about how do you
expect you should ask him yourself and
be curious they seem mad at you tomorrow
more good morning hello
I just street says hello when he say one
thing I always say it to my fans you got
to say mama here come that man but I
want to hear you say you got to hear you
say that to your friend about Honda
Honda mom what do you what do you want
me to say I wanna hear you say mama you
come that man mama here come there me
there you go okay Shamar more we're
supposed to talk about your show okay
but you're allegedly very excited about
because I've heard from reliable sources
that this is a milestone for you what do
you mean well I mean look I have it on
my arm in real life this is not this is
not fake so this is the SWAT tattoo
there you go this is the SWAT tech first
tattoo no I have five tattoos I have on
my back it says carpe diem with Barack
Obama Malcolm X and Martin Luther King I
have a lion I have an affinity affinity
for lions on my right shoulder I have
freedom on my back and then I have a yin
and yang tattoo but this care about the
show this much yeah well I'm not gonna
put my whole resume on my body you know
what I mean but this one it's not just
for hondo and what he does on the show
what I do use it on the show we show it
on the show that's also for me just it's
a it's an achievement to be the lead of
such a powerful show of 25 years in the
game yeah how'd you get this opportunity
I'm so grateful but the deagle and my
own personal life is just it just
represents you know how high you can
soar how high you can fly just dreams
are possible and just keep striving for
the top when you when you when you got
off Criminal Minds and you came onto
this show as you say your first your
first big starring part you got a note
from your mom I did I did I did and my
mother my mother truly is a hero and
she's such an inspiration and she's
struggling with MS but and but that has
even invigorated me and made me stronger
and more determined but she gave me a
very simple card when I left Criminal
Minds cuz i didnt see swat in my future
I didn't know what my future was you
know I just wanted to find the next
chapter and
card just simply says leap and the net
will appear and leap and the net will
appear and I just like that to me to be
brave
you know the unknown but if you believe
in yourself just go for it and just know
and just believe that you're gonna land
on your feet in some type of way that's
a great note to get from your mom yeah
what did you think of the tattoo if you
actually liked it she said she's like
why you want to mess up your body like
question the other tattoos but she likes
that they represent something meaningful
to me
yeah but the swap would she's like that
okay that's that one's pretty yeah shall
take that one meaningful weave and saw
in that clip was how diverse the cast is
yes and that's really being discussed
compared to the original in the 1970s
how is that impacted
well not only is the cast diverse we
have african-american we have latina we
have Asian white and then even our guest
stars but what's really cool is not only
the faces that you see on the screen are
very diverse but the stories that we're
talking about are very diverse and what
what I you know our show touches on
black lives matter human trafficking
cyber bullying immigration but we're not
a preachy show I mean clearly we are an
action-packed thrill ride so we are
first fun and just a good time and you
you hate the commercials and can't wait
to see the show but if you pay attention
to the content we're not we're not
preachy you know we're not a political
show but we are talking about 2017 2018
and beyond so taking on current things
it's also a very physical show how's
your body holding up man man you know
I'm but you get bumped around pretty
good
I do we were talking earlier I do I do
about 90% of my stunts just because I'm
crazy and it's fun but we all have stunt
doubles but I trust me I've had some IVs
you know vitamins just for stamina you
know the hardest thing about this show
is is the stamina yeah being able to get
up every day and do it so you know
you're not supposed to in Hollywood
you're not supposed to talk about your
age but I have no problems I'm 48
my character is 35 to 37 I gotta hide
the grave nobody sees you you see me
running around being hondo but you don't
see me hobbling up my stairs Thursday
September 27th at
and nine central right here on CBS